take me to this vegas game right the
very end at the end of it herbert about
got him all the way back into this thing
how did you see derek carr and that
raiders team figure out a way to get
into the playoffs here
well i thought it was a great team
effort i thought max crosby in the
fourth quarter he completely took over
the game from a defensive standpoint the
level of pressure and i was really
surprised that the chargers did not have
any help for their right tackle nobody's
chipping nobody's double teaming
nobody's giving um max crosby enough
attention man he completely took over
the game on the defensive side of the
ball on our offensive side of the ball
josh jacobs wasn't 100 we knew that but
then when he came in the game he was
effective and late in that fourth
quarter he broke a couple big runs and
and really just imposed that physical
that physical just that physical running
style against that defense
and you know there's always you have a
weird feeling about derek carr right
derek carr i don't know that he gets
enough credit off the field what he's
been able to do to keep this locker room
keep this building keep this team
together to make it to this point in
this season i thought we really heard
that after the game we're talking to
josh jacobs in the way that josh jacobs
talked about his relationship with derek
carr i want to run this clip one time
hear this
josh i want to ask you about derek carr
cause i was watching him warm up and you
could just tell there was something
different about this game what it meant
to him what it meant to his career how
has pairing with carr impacted your
career man i told him i said man
coming into this game i said it's gonna
come down to me and you
i said we're gonna one of us gonna have
to make a play and i told him i said man
you owe yourself this i see the work
that he put in every day i mean he
didn't want to taught me how to read
things on his offensive like quarterback
i'm out there i'll make protection calls
and things like that because he taught
me that oh man i mean this is a big
testament to who he is he's a great guy
on and off the field
and jack
and and jack the fact that josh jacobs
will come out and say something like
that it just shows you the level of
respect that he has because josh jacobs
he's a football guy and you know i told
you this on sunday i said nobody's gone
through more adversity
i mean who's been stronger than derek
carr to go to lose your coach lose some
players and just keep that team focused
and you know when you're going through
situations like that everyone puts the
focus and attention on the quarterback
and the fact that josh jacobs said he
learns past protection and things like
that from derek carr those are the type
of things that leaders do that's not
always at the forefront of everybody's
you know everybody's information so
props to derek carman i mean i thought
and that's why i say we talk about mvp
who's truly more valuable to their team
was it derek carr or was it aaron
rodgers and i think derek carr deserves
to be in that conversation we know aaron
rodgers is going to eventually win it
tom brady should be second but derek
carr should at least be in that top
three or top four because what he's been
able to take on this year the
responsibility and just everything the
way he's continued to play and and allow
this team to ascend it's just been
fantastic
i hear you man it's been amazing to
watch and i really like to hear josh
jacobs say that he and carr got together
individually and said if we're going to
win this game if we're going to take
this group to the playoffs it's going to
be on us it's going to be on one it's
gonna be on two me and you man and
that's what it came down to even when
you get to overtime of that game and the
chargers go down they get a field goal
and now the raiders are coming back down
the field it was josh jacobs just
refusing to go down and fighting for
extra yards and eventually breaking that
first down run that got it over the top
and that's what this team goes through
i'm not a big proponent of first round
running backs or spending those kind of
resources in the running back position
but josh jacobs is the kind of player
that's worth it he's the heartbeat of
that team he catches the ball in the
backfield he breaks all these tackles i
mean he's the reason this is a playoff
team right now he refused to go down one
of the best games of his whole career in
one of the biggest moments
absolutely and i'm gonna tell you
something this offensive line has taken
a lot of criticism throughout the year
and i thought they did a really good job
i mean this is not the best offensive
line obviously they have some positions
where they got some young guys but i
thought this offensive line really stood
up and did an excellent job the one
question i want to ask you or talk to
you about is brandon staley and i think
he has to do a better job of managing
his game managing his team we talked
about the aggressive style he's trying
to come in and change the mindset and
build confidence in that team and we
understand that but at the same time
jack
i mean how do you go for it on your own
18 yard line i mean is that is that
arrogance is that cockiness what is that
or is that flat out stupidity you can't
put your team in a situation like that
when they're fighting their butts off
every single play and then you you put
them at a disadvantage going forward on
on the 18-yard line
i think there's a there's a healthy
level of aggressiveness which he showed
and then there's an unhealthy level of
aggressiveness which he showed in the
biggest game of the year for him i
thought he just pushed it too far showed
a little bit of his inexperience uh
really in a lot of ways and it's
probably the most egregious go for it
moment that i've seen since all the way
going back to the bill belichick one and
we talked about this in the car ride
home after the game and i'll even let
you tell that story but when bill
belichick went for it on about his own
20-yard line this this reminds me of
that moment and i think that the
chargers probably would have won this
game shirley would have been in a way
better position to go win this game this
is early third quarter at your own
18-yard line you're showing that you can
stop this team it wasn't like derek carr
was flying up and down the field it was
the 50-yard chris harris jr pass
interference that put the ball at the
one yard line and then you had the
muffed punt the fumbled punt that also
set up the other raiders touchdown so i
don't think you needed to just give up
on your defense punt the ball go try to
win the game and instead he just goes
full hail mary with the fourth and one
in his own 18 and it totally backfires
and sets up the raiders perfectly
yeah when i look at the charges
defensively they definitely have some
needs on the defensive side of the ball
if they really want to take it to the
next level i think their pass rushes are
good we talked about uchanna new oso
that's your guy he was all over the
field we know about bosa but to me what
they need is they need a big
320 pound big physical defensive tackle
that's going to be a run plugger that
can they can hold two or three people up
that's what they need i look at
linebacker kenneth murray i mean he was
a first round draft choice and he's on
the field when he's on the field they're
making big plays he gets off the field
and it's like okay where's this first
round pick at like he's a first round
pick he's kenneth murray he's healthy he
should be out there on the field and
they haven't gotten a lot of production
from him and then the last point i want
to make is austin eckler we love austin
eckler and he's their best and most
productive player like in those critical
moments you have to give him the
football and it was like okay where's
austin eckley i know justin herbert he's
tough he's got a big strong arm but in
some of those critical moments get it
because he's such a mismatch and he's so
difficult to tackle in an open field i
didn't think they the offensive
coordinator did a great job of getting
him involved in the game late
i think that's a great point i'll tell
you what else that i i was a little
thrown off about watching the charges
and when he picked them a big reason why
was keenan allen mike williams those
were two of their best players on their
whole team specifically on their offense
for sure it took until late fourth
quarter overtime for those guys to get
going i mean justin herbert you got to
trust him a little bit let him go sling
that thing i thought they were a little
conservative early in that game we
really saw some jared cook catches but
you got to get your best players the
ball and to go that long in the game
without getting mike evans and keenan
allen significant touches is almost a
guaranteed losing formula
absolutely and we even talked about
jared cook you were screaming at the tv
throw the ball to jared cook he's wide
open he's six seven he made some couple
a couple catches early that really kept
the momentum going but you know it's
it's just the offensive coordinator
making mike williams making kenan allen
priorities everything doesn't have to be
a five to seven drop back where you're
throwing the ball down the field and you
know integrate some of that quick
passing game in there too to get those
guys involved
yeah i mean you saw what it was capable
of at the end it was like three fourth
and tens on that final drive that they
converted like when herbert lets one go
it whistles out of his hand the one guy
i want to give credit to before we get
out of here is rich basatia right the
head coach who comes in and nobody even
talks about he's under the radar but you
could just tell that he is a rock he is
just a cornerstone rock for that program
and josh jacobs was telling us after the
game he's like when bad things happen in
your life he's the first person you want
to talk to when great things happen in
your life he's the first person that you
want to talk to i thought that spoke
volumes about who he is
and you know what his calm demeanor you
read some of the articles they say his
calm demeanor not having someone yelling
and screaming every time you make a
mistake afraid to come to the sideline
in gruetin as opposed to a guy like this
coach is going to bring you inside talk
to you and really stay patient and
understand and those guys i'm telling i
talk to more than just one raider they
said they love this guy they don't care
about big-name guys coming in here he
understands the tone of the locker room
he understands you know just everybody
and i think he should get another
opportunity even if you sign this guy to
a one-year deal give him a one-year deal
pay him some real some real coaches
money all right pay him five six seven
million bucks allow give him an
opportunity to win this locker room if
you're not a hundred percent convinced
if you are 100 convinced then sign them
to a long-term deal so now you don't
have to worry about
finding your next coach or getting
caught up in that coaching carousel
i think he's earned the right man you're
not going to find a harder circumstance
than the one that he walked into this
year give him an opportunity let's get
to the second one which is the
indianapolis colts the colts have had
one of the ultimate roller coaster
seasons and it ended with just a crash
and burn
two losses down the stretch how did the
colts let this entire year in the
momentum they had built all just run
away from them
dude we talked about this and i've told
you all year i said i'm not a big fan of
this carson wentz carlson wentz was in a
perfect situation he came to the perfect
situation a coach that loved him all
right a coach that wanted him a a great
offensive line you got the lead in
rusher in the nfl as you're running back
okay and you got some big receivers and
pittman jr
ty hilton like the offense was
tailor-made for you and the last game of
the season against one of the worst
teams in the national football league
they beat you so i'm not a big bull i've
never been a big believer carson wins
i've never thought oh kadera carson
wentz away from getting to a
championship i think he's the guy that's
ultimately holding him back we saw him
out in san francisco drop back throw the
ball up three or four times you know and
they come down with the ball or it's a
pass interference things like that
happen but can you stand in the pocket
in those key moments and make those big
throws and he's not able to do it
against the jacksonville jaguars and for
me
the coats not getting into the playoffs
if i don't like frank wright the way i
like him that's a fireball offense
because it's just way too much talent on
this team not to be in the playoffs
sitting at home watching everybody else
this weekend
it's tough when your quarterback is bad
in three of the last four games in the
money time and that's when he struggled
the most right it was new england was
horrible in that game vegas gave that
game away and then comes back in the
final game of the year against
jacksonville all you got to do is just
go beat jacksonville to win team and
he's horrible again so three of the last
four to be at your worst is a bad
situation let's hear from carson wentz
after this game after this season
they're now packing up and going home
here is the quarterback of the colts
it's a bad feeling a completely bad
feeling knowing
that you know we were in control being
in control of our destiny uh last two
weeks and we just couldn't get it done
and it's definitely got left a bad taste
in my mouth a lot of guys mouth
not where we want to be not you know
what we expected either
you know we expected to finish stronger
than we did
and we didn't get it done um it's a bad
bad bad feeling
he kept saying we we but i'm just
looking at him i'm waiting for him to
say i'm the coach i am the quarterback
of this team that's on me i have to play
better forget about we need to play
better as a team if i'm if i'm the
quarterback and i know i stunk it up and
it's for the world to see i'm coming out
and saying you know i have to do better
as a quarterback i was brought in here
to win these games okay you not brought
in here to lose these games they're
paying you 25 30 million a year to win
these football games and to me i'm just
not a big believer and frank wright and
chris ballard the general manager i
think they really blew it in this
situation and they're going to have to
reevaluate after this next year and just
see what happens but i'm not a believer
in cartoon wins we'll see what happens
in the future
because it was a really slow start to
the year they lost four out of their
first five that's what happened to him
and then they got hot that ground game
jonathan taylor shoot he was an mvp
candidate the offensive line quentin
nelson came back healthy clinton nelson
never really completely looked like
quentin nelson to me even when he was
out there playing he had that ankle so
taped up it was almost like he's wearing
a cast on that thing and i've i've seen
him be so explosive back to his days at
notre dame his time with the colts where
he just looks like the best athlete in
the trenches you know anywhere and he
never really looked like that he kind of
looked like he was playing with one leg
at 50 and the other leg hit 100
and just hobbling his way around and i
don't think we ever saw him dominate and
that offensive line needs him to be a
dominator there so let's hear from the
head coach and frank reich after this
season just got away from him
i know it's the day after the season but
as you sit there right now do you expect
carson wentz to be your quarterback in
2022. as far as carson again i i
mentioned this the other day just with
individuals
we love the team we had this year we
knew everyone we brought in this year
uh we expected to play winning football
next year's roster will be next year's
roster um i'm not going to evaluate or
talk about any i don't want to just open
it up with one player and then start
talking about all of them so
hey that's that's his guy you know he's
going to protect his guy and you know
carson wentz you talk about his
confidence being very fragile at this
point in time so frank wright he's doing
the right thing he's protecting his
quarterback but at the end of the day
some of those behind the scene
conversations man you sit back and
wonder what they're actually talking
about
i know if i'm a player in that locker
room i would be frustrated you have a
defense that could create turnovers one
of the best defenses in the nfl you got
the offense like i described it and you
have carson wins and i just there's no
way you're going to get to a super bowl
get to that next level with him playing
quarterback
we'll see what they end up doing i'll
tell you what don't sleep on the jags
either do not sleep on those
jacksonville jaguars because they were
playing some inspired football in this
game and it with the rookie quarterback
they've just been trending slowly
upwards i think trevor lawrence can be
fine in this league josh allen is a
great defensive end great pass rusher
yep then you put aidan hutchinson in
there they're gonna have that first
overall pick that's gonna be two bookend
pass rushers we'll see what they're able
to do let's get to your third one which
is mike thompson hey jack get this done
again go ahead you wanna weigh in on the
jags don't you go
no i was gonna say i think you are spot
on i don't think like everyone thinks
that the jag job is just a terrible job
i don't think it's a terrible job you
talked about like we saw trevor lawrence
man
and like this kid looks really good at
times you know and if you bring in an
eric b enemy you might bring in a buyer
left which or jim caldwell one of those
guys that really get this kid focused
get this locker room built together and
not have so much sep so much so many
separate entities you get a good coach
in there that can work with this kid
like a jim caldwell i like jim caldwell
too because i like his demeanor he's
calm he's patient kind of reminds me of
coach dungey and um i think the
jacksonville jaguars but i think you're
spot on with that assessment
that they could turn into something
that'd be fun to watch down there let's
get you to your third takeaway which is
mike tomlin
mike tomlin he took over as a 35 year
old head coach and really he's been a
trailblazer for a whole bunch of these
young head coaches that have now gotten
opportunities we forget about that when
he first took over at 35 it was like man
that's that seems awful young that's too
young for a first-time head coach in the
pittsburgh steelers not one losing
season for 15 years in the pittsburgh
steelers with old man big ben right back
in the playoffs how in the hell do you
pull this off
man let me tell you something he is a
heck of a coach and just his support of
big ben when a lot of people didn't
support big ben i mean he was very very
supportive of big ben he was like well
this is our quarterback this is what
we're going to do and think about that
offensive line i've been covering and
playing against distillers for years and
this is probably one of the top two or
three worst offensive lines i've ever
seen them have and they go in there they
draft the young running back naji harris
he gets it over a thousand yards and but
it's still a terrible offensive line and
you get big ben he can't move he's stiff
you got receivers dropping passes
to me i don't know how they end up with
a a decent record enough to get into the
playoffs i think he did a wonderful job
but it's the support of big ben is the
motivation he instilled in his players
to keep playing despite all the
different circumstances that laser focus
and him mike tomlin not carrying around
not caring about what other people think
or what they're doing or or just really
focusing on his team and not worrying
about everybody else great job by mike
tomlin
and speaking of not caring about what
other people are doing right so this
this was the team that had to have been
the most nervous about a potential tie
as this chargers raiders game came down
the home stretch so here was coach
tomlin on what he might have been doing
as all the drama one of the games really
in my opinion the game of the year was
unfolding with their playoff chances
hanging in the balance here's what he
was up to
i missed the end of it i dozed off um
i knew i had a work day
waiting on me or i assumed that i had a
work day
waiting on me um i think at one point
oakland was up by 15 and that number
made you somewhat comfortable um i'm
probably better off not having watched
it uh
um so it's probably not as exciting of a
description as you would have hoped
well you know i'm looking toward the
future and the thing that i look at now
is they don't have to pay a quarterback
25 30 million bucks
they need to get back to focusing on
that offensive line and that's the thing
that the pittsburgh steelers were always
known for like when i knew them when i
was playing against them for years the
pittsburgh still is you always had to
bring your hard hat because you know how
physical they're going to do what
they're going to be they're going to run
the football down your throat they're
going to be physical they got duramani
dawson allen fanuca those guys hot few
you know hall of fame um offensive
lineman they got to get back to being
able to control and dominate the line of
scrimmage that's when they're at their
very best and now the second part of
that too is
also being able to go out and sign minka
fitzpatrick he's a free agent they need
to sign him to a long-term contract he's
one of the best safeties in the national
football league he's a do-it-all guy you
could put him in a slot you can put him
down in the box you can keep them deep
he's going to be a guy that's going to
you know demand anywhere from 15 to 20
million bucks a year they have to sign
him i think that would be a smart thing
to do
yeah they just got real gritty down the
stretch this just became pittsburgh
steeler football and they had some hard
games down the stretch of the season
they got a little lucky that lamar
jackson was not in the lineup so that
they could go play the ravens without
them that's a different kind of a ball
game but they win three of their last
four to sneak into this playoffs so they
earned this thing down the stretch and
how about mr watt mr t.j watt who goes
and gets the sack record steals it away
from straight hand this this is an
interesting one though rodney i'm
curious your take on this because with
this 18 week season 17 games the nfl
record book is going to be washed in a
lot of ways right you're going to see
these receiving records break
quarterback records sack records break
uh how do you feel about that as a guy
who played in a 16 game season for you
the entirety of your career
i think they should have records for 16
games and they should have records for
17 games you know i just i just think
that you know
but it's all part of it man you know
when you put up records they're going to
be broken and you know a lot of those
guys they want their records though and
some of those guys say you know i don't
mind my record being broken it's all
part of it um so i don't really have any
like you know passionate thoughts about
it i mean it is what it is at this point
yeah all comes back to the almighty
dollar that's what it is anytime
decisions are made you add an extra week
to the season almighty dollar get to
make a few extra bucks but football in
the nfl to me was one of the last
remaining leagues where the record books
still matter right i mean baseball you
got the steroid stuff you got all that
so it gets washed away football was one
of the final remaining ones where you
could go chase down some of those old
records and it still meant something i
never liked the 18 week season and this
is a huge reason why i'm happy for one
i'm happy for a guy like max crosby with
the raiders who hits 100 pressures but
it's a whole nother thing man when you
got you got an extra week to do it
hey jack but you got it man you got to
come on man like we got a chance to
watch 17 weeks 18 weeks of football i
mean how much fun did we have
how much fun and they ended up capping
off with the last game of the season
with the raiders and the chargers man
come on man it was just a blast we it
was just unbelievable i had a blast this
year
it was it was it was the perfect one to
go out on all right the last or the
fourth of your takeaways the 49ers and
the rams it seems like the 49ers man i
don't know what it is about shanahan a
guy who used to work underneath of him
and mcvay he just seems to have his
number he knows what it is and he just
keeps beating him he got him again in a
game where the rams had led how did he
go do this one rod
they're not physical like
the rams get beat by teams that are
physical when you're physical you can
run a football you come downhill and you
hit them in the mouth like the tennessee
titans does that we've we saw them do um
they they just they can't respond and
that's the problem you know and i just
don't i don't believe in matthew
stafford matthew stafford is a guy that
can put up a lot of points he looks good
but at the end of the day when you put
pressure on him and who has more
pressure on him in these playoffs than
matthew stafford and trust me he
understands that too he knows that he
has more pressure on him than anybody
because the rams gave up a fortune to
get him he's getting paid a lot of money
and expectations are super high they've
traded a bunch of draft picks and first
um you know first round picks now you
have matthew stafford to me i'm waiting
to see exactly can he elevate them to
the next level but i'm not a big
believer in this rams team because i
just don't think they're physical enough
yeah no that's real and that could be an
issue it was nice to see iuk ryan and iu
get going for the 49er side of things as
well they've always needed another
receiver i mean debo samuel is amazing
you finally get george kittle healthy
which has been good and juwan jennings
how about this kid right i mean he kind
of came out of nowhere in this game but
he was clutch it was overtime fourth
quarter had the game tying one to send
it into ot two big catches in overtime
which settled down into field goal range
to go win it so it's new weapons around
jimmy garoppolo guys we haven't seen him
work with at that high of a level yet
but it's certain to come to be a reality
now that the 49ers are playing like this
i tell you what man we always know what
they're able to do with that run game
it's one of the best run schemes in the
entire nfl if they can give garoppolo a
couple of guys that he's comfortable
with you may see the 49ers put together
a sneaky run here because they always
play tough defense when it comes to
january football
yeah but the thing you know the
narrative out there is hey nobody wants
to play the san francisco 49ers why not
why not i would love to play the san
francisco 49ers you want to know why not
because of kittle not because of debo
samuel needs all these weapons because
of jimmy g i want a plan because i don't
believe jimmy g at this point in time he
can come through consistently in the
clutch he has not been able to do it and
hey i'm not a big believer so everyone
talking about hey you don't want to play
the san francisco 49ers yes i do
no question about it i want to play him
and i want to see exactly what jimmy
jimmy g can do on a big stage and if he
can continue to elevate his game each
round we'll see what happens but i
definitely wouldn't mind playing the san
francisco 49ers i'm not afraid of them
well we'll see is right but it's always
an interesting thing when you know that
the quarterback the coach and the
quarterback really the head coach and
shanahan the gm
don't fully believe in their quarterback
and jimmy garoppolo they're not trading
that kind of loot to move up to go get
trey lance which i'm not sure that they
hit on that pick but you're not moving
that kind of loot if you believe he's a
super bowl quarterback right so if the
people in a house that watch him
practice and play and they've seen him
play all these games but they're
watching him on a day-to-day basis
operate if they don't believe in him
it's hard as an outsider to believe in
him but i gotta say i've been impressed
that just the fact that jimmy garoppolo
has been able to put together this kind
of season knowing that because nobody
knows that they don't believe in him
better than jimmy g i mean you can
imagine
if if aaron rodgers was going you know
four fingers on the scotch after they
picked jordan love you can imagine what
jimmy garoppolo had to be feeling after
you trade all that to go get your
replacement lance
yeah you know what and we're we'll sit
back and see exactly what jimmy jimmy
does in the playoffs but at the end of
the day like great players special
players get it done in the big moments
in the big big moments in the playoffs
and if he can't get it done in this big
moment i think the san francisco 49ers
this year definitely or in the future
we'll move on from them
we'll find out man let's get to your
final takeaway which is tennessee the
tennessee titans all year long it's a
team even without derek henry have just
been right in the thick of this thing
man he comes back
at afc it's going through tennessee it's
going to be a home field advantage
throughout for verbal and the titans
no doubt in ryan tannehill he has to be
thrilled that he's getting two of his
best weapons back you get derek henry
and when you bring there when derek
henry comes in it's not like he's got to
run the ball 25 times deontay foreman
has done a great great job of really
holding down the the realm and allowing
him time to come back so when he comes
back you'll see him get anywhere from
say 10 to 15 touches 10 to 15 touches
he'll share and split carries with
deontay foreman now they have this
two-man run game and
really think about aj brown coming back
he's healthy but this is what you need
you need this big guy coming in wearing
down the defense he's a such an
intimidating factor then you get kind of
a change of pace guy that has very
similar power when it comes to deontay
foreman but this is gonna come down to
ryan tannehill being able to run use the
play-action pass being able to hit guys
down the field on deep routes 20-plus
yards and we'll see if ryan tony hill
can do it if he plays with that level of
confidence but when i look at the
tennessee titans i always say this
they're they are the most physical team
that i've seen this year and mike vrabel
i'll speak about mike vrable in a minute
after this but mike vrabel will
definitely be the key
they are and i also think about it derek
henry has fresh legs right you got to
imagine that they brought him back
slowly and they thought about the moment
of when they wanted him back on the
field so i think he's going to be
healthy i think you're going to see a
derrick henry that's healthy is he also
going to be fresh i mean like we talked
about with these 17 weeks i mean these
teams are beat up man like some of these
teams the cincinnati bengals are a
perfect example they needed a week off
like they had to take a week off in week
17. so if derek henry has fresh legs and
now they have two running backs i mean
they go five wide on that offensive line
of people that are just pushing guys
around lawn sapple jones davis
quisenberry all of those guys are really
good players so if they have that with
some fresh leg derrick henry now depth
at the running back position like you're
talking about
man tennessee could really be something
we've already seen them beat the rant
we've seen them beat so many of these
teams were in the playoffs last year
they've already beaten them this year so
you know that confidence is right there
along with it
no question you think about vrabel being
an experienced coach that was a former
player that played and coached in a hot
the biggest moments in the national
football league so he understands what
it takes he'll have his team
fundamentally ready and he'll have them
mentally ready so when they when they
come out they've already experienced it
because vrabel's gonna he's done a great
job of really preparing him for the
moment so when i when i look at the
tennessee titans i'd say this is going
to be a really a hard out and the two
teams that i really like i still like
kansas city and i still like the
tennessee titans it's going to be tough
to beat the titans
yeah like the thing you use for the
49ers which is i you you wouldn't want
to play them i think the titans are who
that really applies to i wouldn't want
to play the tennessee titans especially
having to go to there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports